Today we're going to talk about another
classic of the Contracts Law Cannan
Hoffman versus red owl stores.
We've already discussed promissory
Estoppel several times in red owl.
We will revisit this concept,
but in a different context.
This case asks whether a plaintiff who
relies on a defendant's pre contractual
promises may recover.
Joseph Hoffman,
who together with his wife operated a
bakery and walk Toma what Wisconsin and he
wanted to expand his business
by opening a grocery store.
He contacted Red Owl,
a grocery store chain operating
throughout the Midwest.
Read Al Stores.
We're often operated as franchises.
Hoffman Bay began negotiating with,
uh,
I read al manager named Luca wits to
establish a red al franchise in Hoffman's
town.
Hoffman told the manager he only had
$18,000 to invest in the franchise and
Luca,
what's told them that was sufficient.
From here,
there began a series of moves by Hoffman
made on the belief that he'd soon be a
red owl franchisee in order to gain
experience in the grocery business.
He purchased a small grocery store
in La Toma and move that Luca,
what's approved, but several months
into its successful operation. Luca,
what's advised him to sell it though
Hoffman did not want to sacrifice the
profits the summer tourist
season would bring,
he was assured he'd be operating a
larger red I'll store by the fall.
In the fall,
the Red Alga manager suggested Hoffman
exercise an option to buy a lot in a
different town. Chilton, where he
would build his red al franchise.
Hoffman took the suggestion and it's
September of 1961 he put down $1,000 to
acquire an option to later purchased the
lot after Hoffman put down the thousand
dollars on this Chilton Lot.
Luca, what's indicated quote,
everything is ready to go.
We are set unquote.
But soon thereafter,
Luca Woods told Hoffman the only
remaining hitch in the plan was Hoffman's
bakery. He and his wife would have to
sell it and they did. So in November,
uh,
Hoffman sold the bakery.
He and his family moved to a different
town and he began working the night shift
in another bakery at the end of November.
Right.
Alan Ford Hoffman,
he'd need to invest $24,000 rather than
the $18,000 he originally anticipated.
This number was soon raised to $26,000
in order for Hoffman to meet these new
amounts.
Hoffman's father-in-law
agreed to contribute $13,000
provided he'd be a partner
in the business though.
Read Al Originally told
Hoffman that this sounded fine.
Hoffman was informed in late January or
early February of 1962 that his father
in law would have to agree that the
$13,000 contribution was a gift,
right Al then increased the amount needed
from Hoffman and his father in law to
$34,000 and at that point
Hoffman broke off negotiations.
Hoffman sued Red Owl for expenses and
lost income and the jury awarded him
damages for the sale of the grocery store
sale of his bakery and the option on
the lot as well as incidental damages.
However,
the trial judge vacated the damages
awarded regarding the jury's award
concerning the sale of the grocery
and ordered a new trial, uh,
to be held to determine what the damages
on the sale of the grocery would be.
Both Hoffman and Radel appealed and the
Wisconsin Supreme Court in deciding this
case, first determined that it was
adopting section 90 of the restatement,
which we've talked about before.
So what are the elements of promissory
Estoppel contained in section 90 that
provision states that quote,
a promise which the promise or should
reasonably expect to induce action or
forbearance on the part of the primacy
or a third person and which doesn't do
such action or forbearance is binding
if injustice can be avoided only by
enforcement of the promise.
The court in red owl concluded that read
Al Gave Hoffman a number of promises
and assurances upon which plaintiffs
relied and acted upon to their detriment.
So what are some of the promises that
Red Al made the most prominent was the
promise that Hoffman's
$18,000 would be sufficient,
a sufficient investment.
This is certainly the promise that
proved most compelling to the court.
And certainly the record suggests that
red owl numerous times assured Hoffman he
would soon get the store.
But despite the number of promises
the court asserts existed,
it's actually somewhat difficult to pin
down specific promises that read Al made
to Hoffman rather read.
Al told Hoffman things like we're all
set and everything is ready to go.
These uh,
communications,
these utterances certainly wouldn't be
definite enough to constitute an offer to
form a binding contract.
This indeed was the thrust
of Red Alice defense.
It argued that quote again,
agreement was never reached on factors
necessary to establish a contract.
The court had to determine whether
promissory Estoppel could apply when the
promise in question did not quote,
embrace all essential details
of her proposed transaction
between promissory and
promise.
See so as to be the equivalent of an
offer that would result in a binding
contract unquote in holding that
promissory Estoppel could apply in this
situation.
The court explained that it was wrong
to think of promissory Estoppel as the
equivalent of breach of contract.
The requirements of section 90 did not.
The court said indicate anything at all
about how detailed to given PR proposal
was or how close it was
to a binding contract.
Having concluded that promissory Estoppel
applied there remained the question of
damages.
The court explained where damages are
awarded in promissory Estoppel instead of
specifically enforcing
the promises promise.
They should be only such as in the opinion
of the quarter necessary to prevent
injustice.
Focusing on the primary
contested damage award,
the sale of the grocery store about
which the trial judge had ordered a new
trial,
the court responded to Hoffman's claim
that he was entitled to the profits he
would have had if he had continued to
operating the store during those summer
tourists month by emphasizing again,
this is not a breach of contract action.
We usually see lost profits award as part
of expectation damages where the goal
of expectation damages is to put the
plaintiff in the position he or she would
have been in if a contract
had actually been performed.
In this case,
the plaintiff recovered damages in
reliance the detriment Hoffman incurred by
relying on Red Alice representations
and issue and assurances.
Is there a way you could construe the
profits lost by the sale of the grocery
store as reliance damages?
Well,
absent read Alice assurances,
he'd have a bigger red owl
grocery store in the fall.
Hoffman wouldn't have sold the grocery.
On the other hand,
he may not have purchased the grocery
in the first place and would've had no
profits to gain their buy if he hadn't
initially began negotiating with red owl.
Usually courts will not award lost
profits when a plaintiff is pursuing a
promissory Estoppel theory.
But in Walter's v Marathon oil,
a seventh circuit case decided in 1981
which involved plaintiffs who purchased a
gas station from,
from marathon oil after the company
represented it would provide gasoline.
The court upheld the trial
court's award of loss profits,
quote in reliance upon
appellant's promised to supply
gasoline supplies to them
a pal Lee's purchase the station and
invested their funds and their time.
It's unreasonable to assume that they
did not anticipate a return of profits
from this investment, but in reliance
upon the appellant's promise,
they had forgotten the opportunity
to make the investment elsewhere.
Returning to this case.
In what other ways did Hoffman rely?
Well, he purchased the what?
Toma Grocery and later sold it.
He paid $1,000 to option a lot and Chilton
and he sold his bakery and move to a
new town.
Notice that the award doesn't give him
damages for purchasing the [inaudible]
grocery store that wasn't in reliance
on definite enough of a promise from red
owl or it was if it,
if it was reliance,
it wasn't reasonable.
At that early stage in the negotiation
and reliance damages for selling the Watt
Toma Grocery, we're going to be
limited down. The court said quote,
justice does not require that the damages
awarded him because of selling these
assets at the behest of the defendants
should exceed any actual loss sustained
measured by the difference between the
sale price and the fair market value
unquote.
This doesn't directly award lost profits,
but at least indirectly the fair market
value should reflect the expected
profits from the upcoming
summer tourist season.
So did red owl act in bad faith
in its negotiations with Hoffman?
The court concluded that it didn't.
There was no evidence read Al intended
not to keep any of its offers or its
promises,
but even if red al had acted in bad faith,
there probably wouldn't.
That probably wouldn't matter.
The uniform commercial code imposes a
duty of good faith as Amanda Tory part of
all contracts, but while duties of
good faith arise under a contract,
negotiators typically don't owe
each other any such duty duty.
Then again,
the succession of increasing demand
certainly creates the appearance of a kind
of bait and switch strategy that read
Al was stringing Hoffman along trying to
get more and more out of
this potential franchisee.
The law of promissory fraud can hold a
promise or liable for punitive damages if
the plaintiff can establish that the
promise or at the time of promising of
making assurances intends not to
perform a her promise red Al's repeated
assurances probably aren't enough to
establish promissory fraud but they are
moving in that direction and important
article by Professor Allan Farnsworth
provides a way of thinking about pre
contractual liability that offers some
insights into why reliance
damages are sometimes preferable.
Farnsworth distinguishes between
agreements to agree and agreements to
negotiate.
Unlike the former parties
agreeing to negotiate,
recognize that if they fail to reach
and ultimate agreement they will not be
bound because the agreement to negotiate
is not part of a larger agreement.
There is no possibility of a
claim for a lost expectation.
Indeed,
there's no way of knowing what the terms
of an ultimate agreement might've been
if one had ever been reached.
In such cases,
reliance is appropriate because
that is the only interest,
a party to an agreement to negotiate
reasonably expects should the other party
pull out of the negotiations.
The case teachers,
insurance and Annuity Association
of America Versus Tribune Company.
A case decided the same year Farnsworth
article was published and which
concerned failed negotiations for a 14
year $76 million loan federal District
Court judge Pierre leval warning that
there was a strong presumption against
finding binding obligation in agreements
to negotiate set out of five factor
test to determine whether the parties
had in fact entered in to such an
agreement to negotiate these factors
included the language of the agreement,
the context of the negotiation
with particular attention
to the parties motives,
the number of open terms,
the extent to which the agreement had
been performed and usage of trade.
Red Owl is considered an
incredibly influential case
which often decided as the
catalyst in the expansion of promissory
Estoppel doctrine to the liability for
pre contractual reliance.
The implication indeed are profound read.
Alice suggests that parties must
be very careful in negotiations,
a realm in which representations are
often taken with a grain of salt because
reliance on such promises or
representations may result in damages,
but some argue that the result
of Red Al is in fact unusual.
Professor Alan Schwartz and Robert Scott
studied over a hundred cases from 1999
to 2003 that directly presented the
issue of recovery for precontract or
alliance.
Their research showed that courts
consistently have denied recovery for pre
contractual law reliance and less.
The parties by agreeing
on something significant
indicated their intention to be
bound.
In a sense,
the default not withstanding red owl and
its progeny is that it's not reasonable
to rely on pre contractual promises.